I'll take a phone call from Bobo I know
he'll keep it light and silly hey Bobo
hey don't Howard who is the gatekeeper
for monitoring stunts on Twitter why is
it that you guys are not following me
but you found all the other whack
package I have no idea whoever manages
to follow him what do you care white why
do you care the stern show follows you
because I've been associated with the
show I'm 30 years how do you leave me
out because my superfan Mary Ann from
Brooke my best friend the world captain
Jenks wolfy Bobo and I bought this
happen I have nothing to do with Twitter
Howard but you wanna hear something
insanely insulting yeah crazy we we
follow Eric the actor even though he's
been dead for 10 years is there a real
reason why it's kind of random as no
rhyme or reason who we follow it's
random we we keep an eye on what
everybody's doing but we don't follow
everybody nobody sat down had a meeting
and said let's not follow Bobo that
didn't happen
alright thank you I gotta go Oh Jon's
starting a movement John who John from
Massachusetts yeah John what is your
movement everybody that's a fan that
follows Bobo just don't follow him if
he's that concerned with the show not
following him we could just really get
them all smile yo chillin you're
advocating a movement where everyone who
follows Bobo unfollowing that's the next
big thing yeah how many followers does
Bobo have on Twitter did you start the
hashtag unfollow Bobo 2020 movement
[Music]
Moomin started you mean because Bobo is
calling in about dumb [ __ ] like we
should follow him with our Twitter feed
that now everyone is on following him oh
my god John is the father of the
unfollow Bobo movie he's going to go
down in history with
that's a big day in Howard Stern history
point-like do you think in 10 years if
we're still on the air we're gonna look
back on the day John called in and
started the unfollow babo moment yes
call back in and we can revisit thats
big all right hold on to John's number
we might have to have an anniversary
party poor Bobo oh my goodness bubble
already lost 100 followers yes so Sal
and the wiki unfollowed him but Richard
feels too bad but I know who a salad
somebody came with the idea that
everybody should screenshot and tweet
their unfollow Bobo better call in quick
and stop the movement get him on the
phone I'll break it through him John had
an idea that's big yeah I better tell
Bobo to get ahead of this thing what's
he gonna do I don't know I got bad news
what so after your call right yeah this
guy John calls in right and he says he's
starting a movement he's gonna have
everyone unfollow you all your followers
yeah and now there's a whole hashtag
unfollow Bobo oh no this is a travesty I
can't this is terrible this is like 913
I know well that's why we thought we
ought to call you and tell you Matt let
you discover it on your own Howard I was
trying to make a point right that this
girl wasn't following me I wasn't I know
I know I think he got us Bobo bad news
you're officially down 300 followers now
right now stop the bleeding come on
even Ronnie's trying to unfollow Bobo
but he doesn't
[Music]
let me talk to Ronnie how many Ronnie
Bob I'll let you talk to Ronnie maybe
you could convince him to bottle what do
you got going on the [ __ ] blackberry did
I have you still have a blackberry yeah
I'm gonna change it but anyway on this
[ __ ] blackberry on the original Twitter
site yeah I had to change Twitter sites
because they took off the original
Twitter site so you don't know how to
unfollow you can't I've been trying to
do it you can't good news anyone who's
using a blackberry there's a new
movement now where people are following
Bobo just so they can immediately
unfollow where you gained people but
then they left
hey Bobo let brace yourself you ready
you're down six hundred people Jesus
shopping astronomic please please please
I think you get onto my flight now
please tell everybody Mike everybody
follow Bobo I'm just I'm trying to help
Bobo what was happening Robin are you
saying you support the Untied you
support the unfollow but for what it's
worth bubble I don't support this
movement sometimes the people are doing
their own thing you can't stop a
movement sometimes I don't follow myself
Bobo you sit down yeah I know the
puppets gonna both follow the mail I
know I just checked you're down at 700
oh please please Robin
Marian did you see yes I am
gram way back with a cameo and you know
what your John is just as important as
you are that's your problem all son fans
are created equal I suggest everybody
unfollow you deserve but that explain
like a big baby Mary Ann you're saying
you want a humble Bobo hold on how about
Mary Ann excuse me for one minute
rose-colored glasses of all media of all
stars and he thinks he's the king
well above buh-buh-buh yes are you
sitting down yes you're down eight
hundred oh sorry I have an update you
down nine hundred you are losing ten
followers a second we just did the map
can you believe you lost Mary Ann they
might be she might be a sheep in sheep's
clothing that's an old saying yeah not a
bleep in sheep's clothing why would a
sheep but on shoes quality no no listen
is bubble the expression is a wolf
in sheep's clothing
see that I never heard oh my god to my
90 plus followers on Twitter today taken
upon a goose
I'm telling you well like a snake and
Mongoose clothing snake and a mongoose
Howard yes quick update Jerry O'Connell
just unfollowed him and tweeted out to
125,000 followers to do the same oh no I
don't like this here's some good news
for you what well I've got bad news and
good news what do you want first
give me the bed there's this way the
good news will be the final thing I hear
the bad news is you down 1,200 followers
oh all right this is awful
you want the good news yeah superstar
Michael Rapaport tweeted that he does
not support the unfollow bubble do now
down 1,300 followers oh this is awful
but you got a popular guy like Mike
Rappaport behind you who doesn't
alienate anyone you want some good news
what's the good news
Jerry O'Connell felt bad and now he's
reef following bye-bye you got Jerry
back oh that's great
buh buh someone who has not stopped
following you and has been your
supporter all along is Michael Rapaport
he wants ya all right Mike go ahead well
this is just indicative of what goes on
in the back home with gorillas those
people don't appreciate they treat
people like you know like their [ __ ] at
because be Kyle this is a huge
endorsement to show Michael well wait a
minute I think Michael has an ulterior
motive what do you think he's afraid it
might spread
yeah I've heard about this stop
following Michael Rapaport my Michael
despite your plea Bobo is down 1400 lot
of people are asking and Gary Belafonte
that [ __ ] monkeys a mean-spirited
gorilla you're being accused of being a
mean-spirited gorilla but anyway I
digress Nikki Glaser just jumped on
Michael Rappaport's tweet she says I
will continue to follow Bobo so she's
now on the Wow alright well Michael you
stepped up you certainly March to your
own drum or as Bobo says you're a sheep
in sheep's clothing and he's got a big
tongue Mike yes Jerry
Jeff the drunk never followed Bobo never
will Wow Wow I never will I think the
whole staff in the back office dropped
you know that would kill me kill me
don't do that which that's why they were
trying to get me I couldn't do it Jerry
did you unfollow him I was going to but
it turned out I had never followed him
in the first place follow them oh wait a
sec oh you lost Chris Wilding Ralph
unfollowed him Ralph well come on Ralph
we'll never followed John you never
followed oh wow oh boy well the least
you didn't lose them supports or just
hasn't woken up yet
I don't think knows how to work Twitter
yeah go ahead Joey go to the cold baths
are both following him and they can't
unfollow them that's right they're dead
people with blackberry you're safe and
you're safe with a lot of the dead
people uh-oh what you down 1,600 Oh No
jillian Barberie my favorite she's still
following me right Jillian she didn't
wake up yeah
she's got some time I want to hear from
round please
you know he's kind of reflective about
people oh well know what no he can't
what is it round yeah I also followed
him I'm starting a new movement what you
do is you write a tweet to unfollow Bobo
with his name and pin it to your profile
so anytime anybody goes to your page
they will see it Wow do you know like a
snake in a manga as well she called it
Gary has breaking news I think this is
big a major celebrity has come out in
support of Bobo Stamos who had not
followed Bobo just started following him
samos what is going on in Hollywood I
have to call jogger ball what are you
gonna say to Stamos I'm just gonna beg
him I think dude you gotta unfollow them
Bobo you sitting down are you sitting
down yeah yeah you started the day at
fifty four thousand six hundred
followers we're now at fifty three
thousand oh my god this is a travesty
this is horrible it's fair to say the
country is divided yet again hang in
there and let's see what happens you
know what if they unfollow you they
weren't real fans right look at it that
way that's right alright well you know
Bobo a movement has been born let's hope
it doesn't affect you too much alligator
in the owl